on the spot where zara elena was
attacked hundreds of her friends family
and neighbours gathered to remember her
and to walk her home why am i here
because i just
want to
show my respect and
just this whole sorrow you know in my
heart
led by zara's family the crowd set off
at 2 17 the time in the early hours of
last sunday morning when the 35 year old
was attacked their silent walk sending a
deafening message that violence against
women must end let us stop saying the
same thing
actions actions be kind teach kindness
teach people
not to abuse people
in incident like this they don't make
you feel safe
no
you out of the blue it comes like this
and
you know you are unsafe does it make you
afraid to go out yes it does
zara was an aspiring lawyer and had been
coming home after a night out a 29 year
old man jordan mcsweeney has been
charged with her murder this walk from
where zara was attacked to her front
door takes just 10 minutes and it's a
long street she knew well and felt safe
in but the fact she never made it is a
sign for many here and elsewhere that
society desperately needs to change
too many women and girls
can't go about our country at the time
of day they want to go about they're
imposing curvies on themselves because
they're not safe to go about our country
that's why it's really important us men
and boys have a look at our own behavior
in relation to misogyny sexism and
violence to finally end the violence
that exists against women and girls
thank you so much
for being here
today at the end of the walk zara's on
to dress the crowd this
is our zara
this is our issue
this is
something that we must all change it
must never
happen
again
thank you for being here i mean
zara's family has spoken of the huge
hole left in their lives as a result of
her death a void that is clearly felt by
many iva bennett sky news in ilford east
london